[Music]
mart
yeah uh how would you react oh you know
what first of all yeah where's your
dream car oh my dream car 1967 chevelle
oh okay and you imagined mansion just
bought it
been wanting it for over 25 is that
power steering uh no but you would have
to
like fix it up and my dad had a modern
market
you have to modernize it oh i see it oh
1965
deville oh that's good too what's
preventing you guys from getting your
dream cars
garage space raj space uh for me it's my
asian genetics
asian genetics like you feel like you're
never good enough even though i could
probably afford it right now but i just
feel like
i want to get to the point where i could
like buy like 10 of them and then i buy
one
why it's my asian genetics i don't know
yeah like you don't want to take up that
much of your portfolio
my agent genetics says you can buy one
and i got
something i wanted that's what you don't
have
space so but now i ran out of garage
space
because i don't have a garage but i
really want one so what if you bought
one that was
uh would you buy it like in its original
state and you
and restore it yourself you buy it
restored already and like modernized
i'm open to um either finding one that's
like a rust bucket
and restoring it or finding one that's
completely done but ultimately
the final product i'm after it's called
restomod
where it has like bluetooth it has ac
has all the modern
trims like probably power seats and all
that stuff yeah but the shell of it is
a chevelle why don't car makers start
design designing them like older cars
there's a people mark and they're doing
it with bronco
and they did it with but it doesn't look
like the old bronco muscle cars oh you
mean like
exactly like yeah with the actual shell
of the original ones but then just
modern and everything
they could even make it electric i don't
know i don't care
that would be pretty cool because they
look so cute yeah i don't know why they
don't do that one more question
how much would that be my final product
yeah how much is that um based off the
ones that i've seen that i would like i
think they're about like a hundred and
one people
got such expensive tastes wait but then
how much would it be to
make it modern and if it's no no just
the whole final product
like 100 or 120 and if it's like uh some
of them that are done
super well i've seen them for 250. isn't
the tesla that you have 120 50.
yeah no i don't know that's jio's car
yeah okay i don't know her numbers 100
something it's 120
she doesn't have asian jeans so she gets
the things that she wants but it's elise
right yes oh that's true it is asian
jeans because between the two of us
we're in the same boat
i never i never want to buy [ __ ] i need
to suffer like so much and then finally
it like
like i told myself when i my own
personal
uh savings was gonna get to a certain
amount i was gonna buy this new watch
which is
a panerai that i wanted and i've already
surpassed it by 3x
and i hit it in 2018. and i still feel
bad
buy me one then and you haven't bought
it i haven't bought it you finally buy
it whatever you want i ended up feeling
bad so i bought more
crypto with it okay so i have an asian
i'm mixed and i feel like
my white size overspends and then my
asian side has to make up for it
that's a good balance i just have really
really low
taste so i can the things that i want
are really cheap
and achieve like that too that's true
ask me what my dream car was casey
what's your dream car 2003 prius
why and you can do it don't ask me
personally don't ask don't ask me
because they don't make them anymore oh
true because i don't know how to say
give it a couple more years it'll be a
classic
is it because it has the sticker where
you can ride the
carpool without being in oh my god
that's why we have the same taste means
all the same taste i understand his
brain
i see i see it's an achievable goal you
got a perk
true all right so then bart yes imagine
it's 14 years later
you finally buy this car 14 years 14
years why not five years later that's an
eternity all right
and then tycho's seventeen yeah and then
that's
a lot three months after you buy this
car finally about yeah a bird shits on
it you get a call from taika
yeah who's 17-0 yeah you're dead i
crashed it i totaled it that's
what do you do that's the plot of ferris
bueller oh
he destroyed his car i never finished i
just said he rap spoilers
not spoiling movies for my gosh let's
just think he wrapped your truck around
a tree
is he okay that's all i care about tech
is okay dream car
what do you do as a parent you gotta
break his arm you really
you really want your kid to be okay you
gotta break his head you don't want them
to be like
i lost the leg it's like serves you
right i lost the car [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah well you don't want them
to die or be like too severe but it's
like
lose an arm or two you could tell joe's
not up here like it's like hey man you
[ __ ] up bro do you want them to be
okay and feel guilty for the rest of
life so they
have to try to make it up to their whole
restaurant like a better start you know
also what was the manner in which he he
got his car
because would you let tycho borrow it i
would let him bar for sure yeah
i mean at 17. if he totaled it i think
know i told my mom's car when i was 16.
karma so
i'm like it was bound to happen i guess
it's my bad for even letting your prime
minister
you were happy i think it was her dream
it was a crv
i think that was her dream car i might
run her up actually well you need a
first car that
is isn't that great so that because
you're you're gonna total your first car
you are what was your first car just
treat it like [ __ ] it was a volvo
station wagon
mine was a 1989 honda civic you guys are
bad drivers i
never [ __ ] got into an accident i
just was really bad i like drove over
curbs because i was just like i thought
any car could off-road
like and it might wasn't like a sports
that is so funny
actually fell asleep at the wheel so i
just crashed into it you're like me
bro i never did that but you know i
guess sleepy behind the wheel yeah you
guys are horrible drivers
well for me i hit a cyclist once it
technically was
like it is my fault obviously but i
didn't blame myself because i was on the
freeway
wait what happened when i played myself
no so like my first car right
i i was on the freeway i was coming home
from work and then like there was so all
of a sudden the traffic
just stopped it was like a really abrupt
stop yeah they didn't give you the memo
no right so that's what i'm saying it is
still my fault because i have enough
space
to safely stop so the guy in front of me
just slammed his brakes and then
obviously i was like too close so then i
just it went in
to his the because he was a truck his
car was a truck so it was like
medium my car was this [ __ ] little
like
aluminum can and it just went in like it
was just completely
accordion yeah damn were you okay i was
like i was okay you're okay yeah no it
was fine
i was perfectly fine but the inside of
the whole front was like
dented in wow and they they classified
it as like total
yeah all right well imagine uh your
first car
just happens to be a 3.4 million dollar
car a bugatti
3.4 million that's just dumb you know
honestly i've never heard of this car
ever so the k starts with the p oh the
pajam the pajay one
it starts with the p e u that one p
pigott
what kind of like what country it looks
like the f1 race car and the i think the
side mirrors look really thin and it
goes
it's italian of course pagani damn
three million dollars i think all of
those cars are handmade it looks like
it was really cool what do you mean
handmade you just get a ferrari for them
they're handmade they're like made by a
team that builds it together and they
only have like
it's like a batmobile damn nothing
straight [ __ ] on my cart dream car
this is a 17 year old 17 year old kid
his dad is a billionaire in dallas texas
that owns
a firm and he has a fleet of
uh cars that in his collection and this
happens to be the
very rare uh purple the specific color
of it too
purple pagani i forgot the name of it
well can we see what it looks like
before
that's crazy because i'm like what did
that look like what does it look like
i can't even make out what the car looks
like it looks like
who spends that much on that like well
you're a billionaire i don't care it
could be a trillionaire and i don't
think i could ever bring myself to
at one point dopest house on a beach for
that oh [ __ ] he already has that though
i know but but you can buy it right
there yeah make some money with it 3.4 i
don't think at that point you
care about money anymore that's true
you're just
it's a billionaire yeah this already has
a boat that could fly he had
he has he like he like flicks three
million off of his elbow
he shits gold dust all right here's the
story
so a the youtuber so this kid is a
youtuber too
he's a 17 year old youtuber named gage
gillian
his name is gage his dad is tim gillian
uh who founded the firm they're he's
they're worth billions of dollars
and his youtube channel only has
uh 84 000 subscribers
it's called gg exotics we win
[ __ ] but his youtube channel is
gg exotics
and on his channel all he does is
showcase his dad's luxury cars
so he takes it out for a spin does some
dope videos with it and just kind of
you know does the whole brush your
shoulders show the lavish lifestyle
and even parties on his yachts so that's
what this kid's all about so he shows
off the lifestyle that his dad earned
yeah yes exactly like hey this is what i
guess i was born but imagine how balling
like your family must be for you to be
able to like pretty much go in your
dad's closet and go look at his
socks aren't these [ __ ] tight
that's basically what it is he has 80
000 subscribers by showing off his dad's
socks and [ __ ]
his dad's collection rather than like
tiger's like
this is my dad's underwear he leaves it
out
these are his boxing gloves so then he
takes out this purple car for a spin
here's him posing with that what's he
throwing up he's got to be the most
douches looking dude
i have to say uh so that's his dad looks
like joe rogan
wow that's jack triple h and joe rogan
combined well he's worth billions of
dollars guys his son looks like a
broccoli
true this is uh right after the
uh the the car accident he looks pretty
cool though we're taking that picture
he's not even looking at the camera so
that's pretty cool so sick
and then that is what he happened
how did he do that oh i have a video of
him explaining how he did this
something doesn't quite add up i bet he
sounds very very bad
do you think he did it to get viral
maybe maybe
but it's so much money to go over i
don't think that's worth it
like dude this kid's got like he doesn't
need fame
he's got money here's a wreckage and
that's him over there with his hurt arm
and just kind of like
you know trying to like gather himself
or whatever that's him going
i'm gonna go so viral after this yeah
i'm gonna be in so trouble my dad seems
so mad
but anyways i destroyed my dad's socks
is the car accident
and then this is his explanation now you
guys tell me
whether or not you believe him and i
will play it
hold on 30 miles yeah yeah yeah here we
go dog
get the [ __ ] out of here i got up to
maybe 30 miles an hour
maybe maybe i mean maybe
i didn't go above the speed limit speed
limit over here is 40. i did not go
above
40 miles an hour for sure a little bit
before that i realized the
pagani actually did have a low tire
pressure sign on the speedometer so
we were i was like i might as well just
drive to the gas station foot up and
come right back so i realized the tire
pressure was low but anyways i was
pulling out
normal started going and then the back
tire i knew it was the back tire
the back right i know it because i felt
it when we first pulled out
and we're not when we first pulled out
when we first started going
when next thing you know we just kind of
got sideways shaking real bad
and i was in the middle lane and there
was a median in the left and
there was a tree so we started we
started shaking i lost control i
couldn't hold on to the wheel because it
was just turning
like i hurt my wrist sideways hit the
curb
i really could not stop it i was
slamming on the brakes cannot stop it
hit the curb caught air
30 miles an hour
body language he's like it's just like
more natural it's like not guilty body
language bro your car doesn't fishtail
from a flat tire
it gets stuck even 30 miles an hour now
and if you let go of the gas
it just slows the [ __ ] down too it's
like what someone cut your brakes like
why
why isn't the brake 30 miles an hour
that's such a laugh eventually that low
to the ground like it would just hit the
ground i drive a miata and it's very
similar to that it's like speed wise
it's very lost yeah so you know
i know exactly what you're talking about
it's exactly the same pretty much
like it's just like the same yeah same
yeah and there's no [ __ ] ways
he's probably if he did exit the gas
station
he probably went full throttle lost
control skidded out
and then he [ __ ] drove into that tree
yeah that's because it says that he
drove into a tree right
there's no [ __ ] way you did that in
30 miles per hour and then like
oh my god you can't even hit the brakes
because the stopping power is way
quicker from
under 30. for sure exactly yeah the
performance was totaled like
the impact that was it was smashed to
bits it was like
you know it was almost split now the
insurance cover it we'll see what then
i don't think they want to cover that
what happened is the tree came at me
like oh that was [ __ ] and then i was
trying to steer and a tree came at me
yeah i mean the tree was coming at you
at 30 miles an hour yeah should make it
hurt a little bit more
only a hundred of these cars were ever
produced yeah they don't
they don't make they don't make me what
year ouchy i don't know what year
actually
can they repair it yeah they didn't give
it a year
that's basically he just threw away 3
million 3.4
4 million let's not forget that 400 000
extra oh my god
they could buy you any regular house in
the country would you do if that was
tyka
ah i [ __ ] up for having the sun like
that
i'm gonna punish that i know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you